so when you start to think about um
let's say some of these things that
you've invested in how much of the
investment is based on the idea how much
of it's based on the technology and how
much of it is still based on kind of the
founders or the people and one and the
reason why i think that that's
interesting is if you were to go talk to
kind of traditional early stage venture
capitalists they would say it's people
it's people it's people um and then it's
market how big is the market how
important is the market you know why now
all that type of stuff is it the same
evaluation framework uh kind of in this
digital space or are there different
kind of order of operations or
importance and prioritization that you
put on the various elements of
underwriting a deal
so when we first entered in this space
and just to be really clear we're not a
venture capitalist in a typical sense
right we don't have a fund so everything
we invest out of is out of our balance
sheet so we don't have sort of the
typical sort of uh sort of vclp
structure we're an operating company
and i think this sort of maybe changes
the lens of how we look at investing so
i can certainly understand that if
you're a vc you need to look at the
outcome you might have a you know seven
year horizon so you need to look at the
exit so timing matters perhaps a lot
more for a company like that because a
vc has to think about the right timing
if they sort of are a little bit too
early
those extra few years and where nothing
happens they become quite deadly for for
the returns of the fund for instance
right but for us as an operating company
which i also think is really the model
that i think more companies are going to
sort of do
not just in our space but in general
where they have to invest you know for
for you know relationships for
innovation and for ideas which is really
sort of where we came from we wanted to
help seed the nft ecosystem because we
wanted to build in that space but we
couldn't do everything ourselves it was
impossible to if you're building it in
an open ecosystem then you know you
can't sort of try to control everything
that's not possible so how do we help
make it grow we have to invest and so we
created sort of made these ecosystem
checks you know and invested in
companies like openc and wax and
decentralized and yes of course it was
people but really the people in and of
itself comes from their sort of mission
and purpose and the belief of what was
going to happen
you have to sort of remember that in
2018 generally speaking most people were
running away from you know fungible
tokens already because the market was so
poor at the time you know bitcoin was
like hovering around three thousand
dollars i think if at one point went
below 100 you know like really sort of
you know dark dark days
and then here we are talking about a
non-fungible less tradable less liquid
version of of a sort of kind of
cryptographic token and everyone's like
what are you talking to me about so the
so the investing here had nothing to do
about sort of the classic elements of
timing for instance you know when do you
time it is the market right you know one
could easily argue that in 2018 and 2019
the market wasn't right this wasn't
about that this was about making a
market this was about helping create and
form a kind of future that we thought
could be possible
it was it was sort of a different lens
and so the founders who were already
building in that period of time were
similar in their belief right it was you
know sort of a band of you know really
just a few hundred of us if you think
about it who sort of had a real strong
passion in doing this because it wasn't
for the money because there wasn't any
money to be made in 2018 and 2019
certainly in that space
but you know technology is one where you
want to know that they have the capacity
to build it but certainly with early
technologies like this
it's it's not the it's not the be all
end all because things will evolve so so
i think really it is more in our case
we're looking we look at the people but
in this case also at the ethos and the
mindset of the people you know in terms
of really trying to create sort of
digital property rights as a reality and
a belief that sort of open systems like
this is the most important thing here
that we're trying to build in an open
metabolism and when you start to think
about uh some of these products teams
and uh kind of opportunities is there
anything uh related to geography like is
most of this in asia do you see most of
it in the western world how do you think
about geography as part of the
investments
one of the fascinating things about this
uh opportunity here is that it's really
opened up opportunities from an
investing in a global perspective it
used to be that you know vcs would and
we were we we had the same problem when
we were looking to raise money in fact
anyway brands had quite a bit of
difficulty raising money from
traditional vcs in fact we didn't raise
any money from traditional vcs in the
earliest formations of our business
because you know we were actually based
in hong kong and
and and uh for the classic rule of thumb
was well if i can't see you or travel to
you or you know visit you on a regular
basis then you know that doesn't make
sense for us to invest right which is
sort of you know the rule of thumb back
then
today that's you know partially because
of covet that's all thrown out the
window and the opportunity of course has
been that people are now able to invest
regardless of whether you're vc in
europe or in us
in companies that exist in vietnam or in
the philippines or you know in indonesia
for instance and these were typically
places that would have been ignored in
the past which means that you can now
tap into a global talent pool in a much
more sort of available manner than
before so you know talent is generally
quite global but you know capital itself
hasn't been quite as global in fact cap
you know people used to move to silicon
valley so that it can tap into the
silicon valley money that is no longer
uh no longer true which which which is
uh i think um actually for the better
because it also means that it becomes
more competitive as well in terms of
opportunities and deals and actually
there's more opportunity for the
companies that exist in places like
vietnam which today has become an
incredible sort of crypto hotspot
particularly when it comes to blockchain
gaming or even in the philippines right
which were typically great sort of test
beds for innovation but very very rarely
would they ever attract international
venture capital
when you start to think about um kind of
the types of companies uh there's this
huge focus now on metaverse and
obviously facebook changed their entire
company name to meta uh and i've seen
people debate what is the metaverse
how do you describe that how do you
define it is it a place is it a point in
time is it a thing like like what the
hell is the metaverse
so the way that we think of the
metaverse
is uh you know a place in which we
actually own our digital assets in which
we can actually have two digital
property rights now let me just sort of
drop sort of go back a little bit here
in the sense that i think that in the
last 30 to 40 years we have been
prepared for this moment
in a sense that we have been trained to
be sort of you know
virtual beings as it were
you know with the earliest days of you
know pre-internet services like
compuserve we had these small fledgling
communities which was actually my first
online experience was on compuserve and
then eventually with the beginning of
the early forms of internet you know and
then eventually to to to mosaic and then
netscape browsers and then of course you
had aol
and all that stuff you know as time went
on we went from sort of small digital
virtual sort of existences to where we
are today where there's you know close
to five billion people online for
instance that really become digital
dependents who do everything online
right now i mean if you think about sort
of what is the first thing you do in the
morning what do you do most of the day
how do you end your and your day likely
you're probably doing something on a
digital device which means that you're
already connected in a kind of
pre-metaverse experience right
uh and and so now however the problem
with what people are trying to define
the metaphors from our perspective is to
say oh isn't the matter as just a more
immersive version of the way we're
already sort of
tapping into the digital worlds today
and we would generally disagree with
that it's not vr and ar from our
perspective or any sort of tools these
are ways in which you can experience the
metaverse but that is not the metaverse
itself the way we define the metaverse
is one where there's true digital
property rights in which you can have a
stake and an ownership in
it matters more when you actually own a
piece of that and you know because of
blockchain you can actually now truly
own you know your virtual estate as it
were and you know the metaverse becomes
real to us because it has real economic
benefits it has real sort of uh real
effects in our actual life as opposed to
playing a game which is entertainment
it's fun so we liking the example of you
know those type of environments were you
know that could be very fun kind of like
going to disneyland it's like a tourist
experience it's nice but we don't own a
piece of that and therefore it has no
impact and that's not the better verse
but the metaverse is the place where it
has an actual meaning to us and that is
it can only happen when we actually have
ownership in it